Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new loki season 2 first look video we have
another first look with a bunch more footage in a
completely different episode that they're filming
and silvie is back so i will explain what's going
on with sylvie during the events of season 2.
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're going to
have all the comic con trailers next week marvel
is doing a giant comic-con panel they're supposed
to release the black panther 2 trailer but we're
also going to get trailers and previews for a
bunch of other marvel phase 4 movies and for some
of the marvel disney plus shows there will be a
separate disney plus event for just the tv stuff
happening in september that's what we'll probably
get some more loki season 2 footage because of the
whole connection with kang the conqueror appearing
during loki's season 2 ruling over this version of
the tva like the more comic book accurate version
of kang different variant in a version of him also
appearing in ant-man 3 quantum mania the ant-man
3 movie is supposed to take place in february i
believe that that variant of kang the conqueror
is going to be different from the variant that
we see in loki season 2. but loki season 2 is
taking place after ant-man 3 so like we'll have
already seen another version of kang before loki
season 2 starts but the brand new episode footage
starts with mobius and loki in their traditional
tva uniforms like we saw them in during season 1
before things went really crazy arresting someone
who seems like they've escaped the tva like a
convict who's in one of those tva jumpsuits when
they arrest them and put them through processing
who's escaped and gone through a portal back to
the early 1970s and gone to this mcdonald's
which seems like is taking place somewhere in
the united states during this early 1970s period
i just did a first look video about all the other
footage from a different episode with them in the
1970s version of london i'll talk about that in a
second too because that's obviously taking place
in a completely different part of the planet
but during that same early 1970s era but the whole
idea here is that this person that they would have
arrested the tva the actor doesn't look familiar
so i can't tell who this character is supposed to
be it could just be a complete random person did
something during a different period they arrested
put through tva processing then escaped went back
to the 1970s and decided to go to this mcdonald's
to get something to eat so if it wasn't clear like
all this mcdonald's fare here is set during the
early 1970s so it's not like they're arresting
him here and then putting him in the jumpsuit
he was already in the jumpsuit when he escaped
back to this place like he escaped again and the
big idea is that they run into a version of sylvie
who is wearing this early 1970s mcdonald's uniform
so it's unclear if she's been working with them
as part of this but because she's not wearing a
tva uniform i think the idea is that she's been
running through time and space doctor who style
trying to hide out from this new version of king
the conqueror after what happened with her killing
he who remains at the end of season one so i think
that's why she's wearing the mcdonald's uniform
like she's been pretending quote-unquote to work
here so far that's why she's so casual about it
where loki and mobius are wearing the traditional
tba uniforms like the whole idea is that when
season two picks up loki explains to this version
of mobius because it's a new timeline it's been
rebooted who he is how he knows him everything
that happened during season one and why they were
friends why he's not a threat it's kind of like
him replaying the events of season one on a speed
run loop at the very beginning of season two like
okay we've already done this i'm not evil i'm not
trying to create nexus events i worked for the tva
but the timeline rebooted and that's why you don't
remember me but the difference with sylvie at the
end of season one is remember she's the person who
pushed loki back to the new tva but the timeline
had already rebooted by the time that he showed up
sylvie stayed at the end of time then killed the
version of kang and took his time travel device
and that's how she escaped the end of time that's
how she's still alive so if it wasn't clear it is
meant to be the exact same version of sylvie
in the exact same version of loki from the end
of season one like silvia and loki i think are
supposed to be the only versions who remembered
what happened except for obviously the version
of king the conqueror that's ruling over this tba
he would remember the events of the kang
multiverse war because he's been busy fighting it
in the same way that he who remains remembered
everything that happened before the first kang
multiverse war because he says that he fought
it and won it now they're just saying that when
he died the timeline rebooted things went a little
bit differently and this other variant of kang won
the war obviously it's really funny seeing sylvie
dressed up like a 1970s mcdonald's worker but i
think the other really interesting thing that's
going on here too is that loki is legit working
for this new version of kang because it seems
like he's just doing his normal duties as a tva
employee so what they might be doing is just
trying to figure out what's going on with this
new version of king of the conqueror part of the
mystery of season one was learning that there was
a version of kang in charge of everything he who
remains version of kang even though he likened
himself to the devil like you probably think i'm
the devil but everybody else is so much worse
like wait till you meet my variants well we're
meeting one of his variants in season two so i
think part of the idea is in loki trying to figure
out what's really going on with this new version
of kanga like is he actually worse what is he
doing that's so much worse than he who remains
because remember all this is heading towards
a version of secret wars so like eventually
they're going to be leaning more and more on the
king multiverse war and i think instead of god
emperor doom like during the secret wars comic
book arc they're going to lean more heavily on
a version of kang being responsible for all
the incursions in the eventual time runs out
lead up to actual secret wars in battle world
even though it does get confusing when you talk
about the difference between the alternate
timelines because that's really more loki
season 2 stuff is all the alternate timelines
and the alternate versions of kang that pop up
alternate universes which they got into during
doctor strange and then alternate dimensions
the way that marvel's referring to all this stuff
is they're just calling everything all those
different concepts all part of reality itself and
the whole concept of secret wars is that reality
itself starts to crumble until just remnants of
it are left and they create battle world with that
so like all of reality in the mcu multiverse is
everything that exists all different universes all
different dimensions in all different timelines
in part of the reason why i think that the version
of kang the conqueror that we see in ant-man 3
even though he'll be a very comic book accurate
version he won't be the last time we see kane
because like obviously you want them to defeat
the villain at the end of the movie but the whole
idea is that secret wars is still a long ways off
that's why they said there's going to be
multiple versions of kang different iterations
of the character from different variants across
different movies in marvel disney plus series
i don't think they'll all be versions of king the
conqueror like i think we'll see scarlet centurion
at some point we'll actually see a version of
rama tut they also referenced him during the
moon night series like all different versions of
kang that you saw pop up in the avengers comics
so far we've only seen about three or four of
them at least referenced in some way but that's
only about half of them and i do think eventually
they will pay off a legit council of kangs where
you see a bunch of them on screen together like
you see a version of that during the loki season
1 finale but it was really just him talking about
it in passing like oh at this one point we all did
meet up across the multiverse and share technology
cannot wait to see that avengers endgame version
of a bunch of kangs all just fighting this war
with each other give me avengers end game in that
final battle but just make them all different
versions of kang from different timelines the
only reason i think that they would use an early
1970s mcdonald's for this particular location like
yes it is funny that they go to a mcdonald's like
this tva criminal goes to a mcdonald's and sylvie
decides to hide from this new version of king
the conqueror at a mcdonald's in the 1970s but
why mcdonald's of all places like there are plenty
of funny places that they could go to usually when
people talk about old-timey fast food restaurants
like mcdonald's for instance at this point in
history they weren't using a lot of preservatives
so like the meat tasted better everything on the
menu is a little bit different tasted a little bit
better so that might be part of the episode like
the reason why they come to this point in history
in this mcdonald's is because the food on their
menu tastes way better than the food on their
present day menu cannot wait to see what loki and
sylvia are going to do during season 2 to further
make secret wars time runs out happen even faster
like how are you going to break the multiverse
again this time the crazy thing i could possibly
think of them doing together that would break all
of reality would be them trying to have a baby
together like would that even be possible because
technically they're supposed to be biologically
identical with a few minor differences the only
thing that's different about the other episode
footage that i did a video for is that we know
that it takes place around 1974 because all the
movies that they feature during this london cinema
that they go to for this particular adventure in
this episode were released in 1974. most of these
are real movie posters the one exception here to
the 1970s movies though is that it's kingo's very
first bollywood movie that he starred in at least
that we know about like he makes it sound like it
was his first movie remember he was living with
sprite in macedonia but he left her to become a
bollywood star because he just got tired doing
what they were doing because nothing had happened
in so long and the big joke about a lot of kingo's
movies is that a lot of his movies are parodies of
things that happened during the avengers movies in
the past because all them lived through the events
of the avengers movies and a lot of his movies
were parodies of things that they themselves
had done as eternals like in present day he's
making the legend of icarus and he's dressed
in a version of icarus's comic book costume
the branding on the bus in the background too is
meant to be a reference to avengers end game like
he made a bollywood version of avengers end game
after avengers end game came out they've kind of
done that in the marvel movies so far where you
see parodies of movies within movies like fake
movies in marvel movies and the funny thing is
that they're all made by goodman productions
it's an easter egg for martin goodman the person
who actually owned timely comics which was the
predecessor of marvel comics like martin
goodman is the person that hires stan lee
as a young man eventually he hired jack kirby
and then once you get to the 1960s is when
most of the major characters that marvel that
people think of when they think of the classic
marvel characters actually wound up debuting in
the comics namor during the black panther 2 movie
is like one of the exceptions to that they call
him the first mutant is because he debuted as a
comic book character before a lot of the other
x-men characters who were mutants we'll see if
they explain namor being a mutant inside the
mcu because like literally we just had the miss
marvel finale episode and there was a major x-men
twist i don't want to give away big spoilers for
that during this because obviously loki doesn't
have a lot to do with what was happening during
miss marvel but like now inside the 616 universe
we have official x-men even though technically
scarlet witch billy and tommy and even quicksilver
were kind of like mutants before that but the way
that they acknowledged that was kind of in a
roundabout way just in the miss marvel finale
they literally said the word mutant out loud which
they had not done before because all the marvel
comic con trailers are dropping next week like
i said i don't think that we're going to get a
loki season 2 trailer but i will do trailer videos
for everything that releases there's going to be
a lot of really cool stuff so make sure to enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that while
you wait for everything click here for all that
other loki season 2 footage that i did a video for
earlier and click here for all my thor love and
thunder alternate ending and deleted scenes video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!